there's a bunch of different
technical aspects i want to ask you
about on the cardinal side so
first maybe on the scaling side what is
hydra
how do how does hydra compare to other
different ideas for scalability like
roll-ups
yeah main trade-offs with respect to
security ux
um anything else you want to then you
want to talk about
i have to have a little bit more energy
lex come on you know what i need
i need that coke machine that you
mentioned the the thing that converts
water to cocaine
cocaine from director bullock we'll
leave that we'll leave this in right
yeah um isomorphic state channels that's
a that's a great topic right it says
word salad of cryptographic terms uh
whether lightning hydra roll ups any of
these things really what you're trying
to do is say okay
if i do it on layer one it's slow and
expensive what i'm going to do is batch
something
somehow some way and then do it in a
different system
where it's fast and cheap
and what i'm doing with that is i'm
losing some of the security guarantees
of the base layer
and admitting a slight higher degree of
this of centralization
but then i get super fast settlement
i get super low cost transactions and
potentially i may even be able to get
distributed computing
meaning that instead of having the smart
contracts run in a replicated system
they can run on a single node like a
stake pool
and their stuff is different from the
other guy's stuff
so you go from a system of of capacity
of whatever it is to a system of
n for the totality of all the stake
pools so
basically hydra is just the next
generation of that
when you have the ability to tinker with
the accounting model and
the layer two solution is is co-designed
with the layer one solution so it's like
what lightning would have been
had lightning been co-developed when
bitcoin came out there had been special
provisions made in bitcoin specifically
to accommodate lightning
and it would have made it very easy for
you then to move inside the system
outside of the system and have
security properties preserved like
availability for example
or fraud resistance say oh is you can't
steal the money or these types of things
where things get really complex and this
is why hydra's novel
over lightning is when you want to move
beyond payments to state management
okay so payments are just i want to move
between alice to bob as quickly as
possible as low cost if possible
so for example um i have a micro tipping
application like change tip on twitter
or
you know like a video i'm watching
youtube video like maybe this video in
the future and people really like it and
they click tip and you get five cents or
something like that
okay so that's an example of a perfect
payment application
and that's great but what happens when
you actually have a rich smart contract
like a dex
or you know you want to do a video game
or something like that you want to run
that off chain
but then there's some reconciliation on
chain that happens
so a state channel basically lets you do
that but
it's a lot more complicated and there's
a lot more to think about
so hydra basically just has its design
a collection of ideas of how to do that
and the current paper
is for a single head the next thing you
do is composition
so you go multiple heads and there's a
routing protocol between them and then
eventually create these tail protocols
for when things get asynchronous
so instead of always being aligned and
always being available what happens if
they die for a bit and then they come
back and you can create all kinds of
guarantees that your funds won't be lost
or locked forever
or things like that there's a failure
recovery mode for this type of stuff
and basically the idea is leverage what
lightning has already achieved with
bitcoin
but then take advantage of the fact that
you have a more expressive accounting
model and a more expressive programming
model
so you can just physically do more and
you can put more crypto inside that
thing
now contrast it with rollups really that
is just saying
you're going to take some thing batch a
bunch of transactions together and
you're going to generate a proof
and then what you can do is whenever you
see some part of that history you can
check it against that proof that's
rolled up and the closely related
concept of recursive snarks that you'll
see a lot there's things like the mena
protocol
or other things and basically the idea
is that whenever you see something
you can always generate two proofs an
existential proof so the coins exist
and a non-existence of a double spend so
you can always check those two
properties and the proof is
verifiable and logarithmic time ideally
so you can have giant amounts of data
but it's very small the actual proof is
concise
okay so they're just different boats for
different floats
the advantage of a layer two network
where there's actual channels and
there's interaction in their service
providers
is the channels can eventually scale in
the collection of things that they can
do
and eventually they can become
interoperability networks between
cryptocurrencies
so at some point we could modify the
bolt spec and make it somewhat
interoperable with hydra
and then what you could happen is you
could use it as a bridge to actually do
cross-chain traffic
and send transactions between the
systems you don't really think about
that too much when you're talking about
roll-ups that's more of
optimizing what you have within the
system within the change so
can you elaborate how is possible do
cross-chain uh
traffic well you already have the
intermediary you have the channel
operator and
you already have lightning switch
protocol right and you just build a dex
that runs within that system
and they can swap assets or you can do
wrapped assets so you
like low cost i guess you could just
switch
yeah the same thing unless you batch
things on one will actually batch the
other so if lightning works on bitcoin
and
hydra works on cardano you can
eventually bridge these two together and
create a way of moving back and forth
and the same things that make
transactions in and out of that network
cheap will make creating wrapped assets
cheap uh at least on the bitcoin to
cardano side you can't create assets on
bitcoin another flaw of bitcoin that
they've never fixed
what's your thought about layer two
technologies in general is there stuff
you're excited about we talked
quite a bit about lightning network
hydra i mean these ideas do you think
there'll be somebody that wins out or is
this going to be this kind of dynamic
thing that
we just keep building different ideas
and they all interact with each other
it goes back to biology that cell
differentiation concept
is you have to build specialized tissue
to do things the point of layer two is
to extend the network
it's adding a foot it's adding an arm
it's adding a brain it's adding a heart
it's adding eyes
giving you additional senses you have
years now so when you add these layer
two products like a taliprism is a
perfect example of that we don't have
identity at the base layer of cardano
it's a real bad deal to do that
because then china will come in our u.s
will come in and tell you how to do that
we do the layer 2 protocol that's
blockchain agnostic and then the user
can decide when and where they need an
identity and then bring that identity
into the system
and if you designed it right when they
bring it in it's very easy very fluid
and suddenly the experience enhances
everything just gets better
oh wow okay now i can use all these
regulated things they go from gray to
green in the app store that's so cool
or oh wow now i can send to human
readable addresses because if i have an
identity and you have an identity we can
alias them with some name space
and now i sent delex instead of some you
know
horrible back 32 address structure okay
so that's
that's really what you need to do with
layer two is say okay each layer two
protocol is meant to do something either
gives me payments
or lower customer contracts or
interoperability or
identity and then it's a marketplace so
you should have blockchain agnosticism
with your layer two solutions and so
you can mix and match and choose
whichever collection of services you
need and
that's actually how it works these days
with microservices and these other
things and
cloud software you know every firm is an
aggregation of dozens of providers and
basically that composition of them is
your software stack
you